escaping Russian occupation before it
becomes nearly impossible zvetlana and
her daughter Karina just arrived from
the Herson region
hours before a referendum organized by
Russia is due to take place
about 70 of people are jobless we were
five months without any mobile
connection the food is coming from
Crimea and we have to pay in Rubles they
have been telling us that our hometown
is part of Russia and it was liberated
from Ukraine Karina's husband had to
stay behind because men of fighting age
aren't allowed to leave
that's why it took olix C and his family
four days to travel from luhan's to the
Ukrainian controlled part of zaporija
despite her permit issued by the
separatists his wife Gula tells me she
was worried he would be mobilized
Alexi says Russia's referendum is a sham
and now is the time to choose sides
there are people who are going to vote
there are people who really believe
afluhensk joins Russia life will become
better and they'll be happier I'm
surprised because most of them work for
Ukrainian companies they earned a good
living now they have nothing but they're
supporting Russia
people still living in zapporita her son
and the donbass will be asked if they
want to join Russia Russia doesn't fully
control any of the four regions with
this so-called referendum is taking
place and the areas on the Ukrainian
control come on the regular attack day
and night this is the latest one in the
Heart of the City
one of the several That Rocks the purija
early morning the target was a hotel set
to host displaced people on their way
further west
people like Tanya and Yulia who made
their journey together from Melita Paul
it's painful her parents stayed back
home part of an older generation
nostalgic about the Soviet Union Julia
shows us a video where she was taunted
by collaborators and Russian soldiers
forced to praise the Russian motherland
and sing the national anthem
I kept my children at home at school
there was too much pressure on them they
would get punished if they spoke
Ukrainian I'm afraid I won't be able to
return home after the referendum there
will be special permits for people to
get in and out of there
no one here doubts the outcome of the
referendum the vote has already been
discarded by Ukraine and its allies but
Russia will use it to stretch its
borders closer to Western Ukraine
put up the Hamid al-jazura zaporinja